I've been hearing about alternating sauna with cold, yuck to cold, but any benefits in
alterating sauna with cold pack directly over a breast lump, I think I could head over
that if it was a direct cold instead of a cold water bath. I think you're saying absolutely.
So, cryotherapy or cold therapy can be extremely beneficial. The truth is some people do
really, so there's a deal. So, most people are doing a sauna to help with detoxification.
So, they're doing a sauna to help them utilize their skin as a portal of detoxification.
They're not really doing a sauna to raise core body temperature because
it's really pretty difficult to raise core body temperature with a sauna.
But the idea of cryotherapy is to decrease inflammation. So, even with doing physical therapy
on an injury, okay? There's huge benefits to creating a pumpy action of alternating hot and cold
in any given session. So, you have an injury to a leg muscle, you're going to ice it,
then you're going to put heat on it for five minutes, then you can ice for five minutes,
then you're going to put heat on it for five minutes and put ice on it for five minutes
to get a pumpy action through the tissue. Some people do real well with that, but I will tell you
just through experience in helping people with musculoskeletal issues, some people do real poorly
with any of these, meeting any of the three, what I just described, alternating hot and cold,
five minutes hot, five minutes cold, five minutes hot. Number two would be just heat therapy,
number three would be just ice therapy, cryotherapy. Some people do real well with cryotherapy
and it decreases inflammation and it could really help an issue. Some people end up with reactive
hyperthermia after cryotherapy. So, they don't do well with ice and some people do real well with
heat and some people, heat causes just a greater amount of inflammation and worse problems. So,
that's just the next bag of how we're different, everybody's different, how your blood vessels are,
so you're just going to try things. So, I would be hesitant to, hey, I'm going to do a sauna,
help sweat and the baby put an ice pack over my breast towards see how that reacts, how I
react to that, give it a try. Like Debbie just said, what do you think about jumping in a cold shower
after a sauna? Hey, I know the fins used to take a sauna and of course the fins don't call it a
sauna, it's a sauna, okay? You're in Minnesota, you learned how to pronounce things the
finish way. So, you take a sauna and then you go roll around the snow in your outdoor sauna,
that's how you took a bath. So, that was common, the fins basically used a sauna or a bathhouse,
they didn't have baths, they just did a sauna and then they'd roll around the snow and it would
clean, that's how they would clean themselves, they didn't take a shower. So, yes, you could do
those things, so I don't think it's too much of a shock for our cancer patient, let's say you have
to go roll around in the snow and I might even say you have to go take a cold shower but even try
and put an ice on your body in different spots whether you're over your cancer or over your liver,
try some different things like that to get a pumping action and you might respond real well to it,
you might go, oh my gosh, I think that made it worse, it hurts and I don't think that was good,
okay? They don't do that and they can try something different. So, the truth is, I think every person's
body is different, how your vessels are going to react is different, that's really what it is,
is how your vessels react. So, but give it a try, I think it's safe to give that a try for sure.